جددت اوكرانيا اطلاق صفارات الانذاري في
مقاطاعتي تشيرنيف وسومي ذلك تحذيرا من
ضربات جويه روسيه متوقعه وافدت وسائل
اعلام بان صافره الانذار هذه هي الثانيه
في تلك المناطق خلال فتره قصيره كما يشن
الجيش الروسي ضربات صاروخيه وجويه على
مواقع حيويه اوكرانيا خصوصا عقب الهجوم
الاوكراني على القرم في الايام القليله
الماضيه وفق وكاله الروسيه
وبالتزامن شنه القوات الاوكرانيه هجوما
مضاده نجح في اجبار القوات الروسيه في
باخموت على التراجع وقال القائد العسكريه
الاوكراني ان القوات الروسيه تراجعت
لمسافه تصل الى كيلو مترين في بعض مناطق
باخموت
من دونا انضموا الينا مراسل العربيه رائد
الاغبر رائد مرحبا بك معي في هذه النشره
رائد حديث عن هجوم اوكراني مضاد هذا
الهجوم لاي مدى اجبر القوات الروسيه على
التراجع فعلا في باخموت وهل تراجعت فقط
كيلومترين
نهارك طيب نايف الهجمات الاوكرانيه
المضاده بالفعل هي
مستمره منذ عده ايام ولابد ان الذخيره
والدعم العسكري الذي وصل من الغرب لايدي
القوات الاوكرانيه لعب دورا كبيرا بهذه
الهجمات وانطلاقها لكن هذه الهجمات لم تكن
يعني مقصوره على باقي شملت مدينه افديف
كمدينه مارينكا اوغلادار مناطق عديده شنت
فيها القوات الاوكرانيه هجمات مضاده لكنها
كانت محدوده حيث كانت التصريحات الرسميه
والمعلومات من ارض المعارك ان القوات
الروسيه تمكنت من ايقاف هذه الهجمات ولم
تسمح للقوات الاوكرانيه التي كانت ترغب
بالعوده والسيطره على مناطق خسرتها سابقا
ودفع الجيش الروسي للانسحاب بخصوص مدينه
باخم يعني
المصدر من المعارك فعلا هناك سيطره للقوات
الاو على عده احياء وعده مناطق ربما تكون
حسب المصدر من المناطق الغربيه لكن اليوم
ظهرت فيديوهات اظهرتها وكالات الانباء
الروسيه تؤكد ان قوات فاجنر وصلت الى اخر
المدينه والحديث عن اكثر من نصف كيلو متر
حسب التصريح الرسمي للمقاتلين من فاجنر
لاكمال السيطره على المدينه ربما تكون هذه
العوده للقوات الاوكرانيه في مناطق اطراف
المنطقه الغربيه وليس في العمق ربما يكون
التقدم لقوات فاجنر في نواحي والعوده
لقوات اوكرانيه من نواحي اخرى ما زالت
المعالق الضاريه ومحتدمه بالفعل في تلك
المنطقه الغربيه وهنا كر وفر او تقدم
وتاخر في هذه الايام يتقدم الجيش الروسي
احيانا وينسحب احيانا حسب المصادر من ارض
المعركه هناك نايف لا بد من التذكير
بعجاله ان اليوم يشهد او يصادف ذكرى
الاستفتاء الاول من اجل الانفصال عن
اوكرانيا اليوم حذرت السلطات من التجول
والخروج الى الشوارع ونصحت المواطنين بعدم
الخروج من اجل يعني تحسبا من اي قصف يمكن
ان يصيب قلب المدينه مع استمرار القصف
الاوكراني على اطراف المدينه واصابه عدد
من المواطنين لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات